necesitamos encontrar el vértice y el
eje de simetría de esta gráfica y bueno
creo que el punto más importante de este
vídeo es que entiendas que es el eje de
simetría y el vértice de una parábola
así que para refrescarnos un poco en
estos dos conceptos vamos a ver si la
parábola se ve más o menos así el
vértice sería el punto que está más
abajo de la gráfica es decir su punto
mínimo ahora si la parábola abre hacia
abajo como ésta
entonces el vértice es su punto máximo o
el punto que está más alto y el eje de
simetría es aquella línea en la cual
puede reflejar la parábola en ella y que
sea simétrica ese es justo el eje de
simetría es decir la parte de la derecha
es el reflejo de la parte izquierda de
la parábola a lo largo de este eje y en
una manera general para poder saber si
un parábola abre hacia arriba o abre
hacia abajo es que pasa lo siguiente
esta tiene un coeficiente positivo al
lado de la equis cuadrada mientras que
se abre hacia abajo en el término de la
equis cuadrada tenemos un coeficiente
negativo pero bueno vamos a ver esto con
mayor detalle así que trabajemos con
esto y por
lo que quiero que hagamos es crear la
intuición de cómo se procede estos
problemas y qué es lo que vamos a hacer
con esta función porque de hecho hay una
fórmula podrás aplicar la fórmula pero
no sabes de dónde viene todo esto así
que lo importante y en lo que me quiero
basar en este vídeo es que vayamos
trabajando en la forma de la intuición
en cómo se resuelve en este tipo de
problemas y entiendas perfectamente bien
qué es lo que está sucediendo lo voy a
fijar en esta ecuación y es igual a
menos 2 x cuadrada más 8 x más 8 y lo
primero que voy a hacer es factorizar
menos 2 un menos dos que multiplica
quién bueno multiplica a x cuadrada
menos 4x y hasta acá hasta el final voy
a poner este menos 4 y lo estoy poniendo
hasta acá porque lo que voy a hacer es
aquí completar el y no me cuadrado
perfecto es decir me voy a fijar en la
expresión x cuadrada menos 4x y voy a
completar de aquí el binomio cuadrado
perfecto y para esto voy a decir que el
número de tengo que agregar a esta
expresión para que sea un binomio
cuadrado perfecto 10 4 si tú te fijas en
el número que está al lado de la x me
queda menos 4 y menos 4 dividido entre 2
es menos 2 elevado al cuadrado me da 4
cuando que veo que esto
cuadrado perfecto pero yo no puedo
agregar cuatro de la nada sé que
necesito este cuatro pero no lo puedo
agregar nada más porque si recuerda que
lo que tengo que hacer es restar cuatro
para que la igualdad se mantenga con
esto va a seguir equilibrada mi función
y entonces no ha pasado nada o al menos
dan a grave y bueno x cuadrada menos 4 x
4 lo estoy poniendo así porque esto es
un vino en el cuadrado perfecto esto es
lo mismo que x menos 2 elevado al
cuadrado entonces debemos escribirlo x
menos 2 elevado esto al cuadrado date
cuenta que de aquí sale el x cuadrada
menos 4 x + 4 y bueno después tengo
menos 2 que multiplica esto y al final
tengo menos 4 menos 4 lo cual me da
menos 8 fíjate que no había hecho nada
con este menos 4 y este menos 4 y bueno
ya que tengo esto ahora lo que voy a
hacer es distribuir de nuevo el -2
primero de la factory cm y ahora lo voy
a distribuir para que me quede mucho más
clara esta expresión y me queda menos 2
que multiplica primero a x menos 2 al
cuadrado y después menos x menos me da
más 8 por 2 16 y entonces esta expresión
de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
a decir que es igual a menos 2 que
multiplica a x menos 2 elevado al
cuadrado más 16 y bueno para que hice
todo esto porque aquí vamos a poder
encontrar una manera mucho más sencilla
el vértice fíjate bien lo primero que
quiero que observes es que x menos 2 al
cuadrado como es una cantidad que está
elevando al cuadrado siempre es positivo
y ahora date cuenta de esto si yo a este
número positivo que siempre es positivo
lo multiplicó por algo negativo por este
menos dos entonces me da que esto
siempre es negativo esto es muy
importante menos 2 por x menos 2 elevado
al cuadrado es siempre negativo y por lo
tanto entre más grande mente un número y
lo eleva al cuadrado y después le
multiplique por menos 2 me va a salir un
número mucho más negativo y si este
número mucho más negativo le sumó 16
pues entonces me da pie para preguntarme
cuál es el valor que puede tomar esta
función que mete mi valor max
y bueno si te das cuenta mi valor máximo
es cuando esto de aquí valga cero porque
si esto de aquí vale cero será al
cuadrado es cero por menos 20 y el valor
más grande que puede obtener es 16 es
decir el valor más grande de esta
función se cumple cuando x menos 2 es
igual a 0 porque en cualquier otro caso
lo que voy a obtener son números más
pequeños porque estoy restando a 16 y
bueno x menos 2 es igual a cero si x es
igual a 2 y entonces si x vale 2
entonces 2 menos 20 al cuadrado es 0
menos 20 y entonces obtengo que vale 16
y esto quiere decir que acabo de
encontrar mi vértice de esta parábola no
invente de esta parábola está en el
punto x igualados e igual a 16 en el
punto 2 16 es el vértice me para hablar
porque estoy encontrando el punto de
esta función en el cual tengo una
propiedad muy importante es el punto más
alto de esta función cualquier otro
punto kilómetro ven y gráfica de esta
función va a ser menor que el vértice de
esta parábola y bueno una vez que ya
tenemos el vértice de esta parábola
sería muy bueno graficar lo así que aquí
tengo uno
este es el 2 y después 2 4 6 8 10 12 14
16 estoy parado justo aquí aquí va a ser
mi vértice de mi parábola y entonces si
estos niveles se me parábola ya sabemos
cuál es el eje de simetría de esta
parábola es justo este mismo si es una
parábola que habla hacia abajo entonces
aquí tengo mi eje de simetría y bueno
solamente por curiosidad y para
quitarnos de la duda de cómo se va a ver
la gráfica de esta parábola vamos a
buscar otros dos puntos para poderla
graficar si yo pongo que x vale 0 le va
a salir 0 0 y 8
es decir cuando x vale 0 10 vale 8 que
estamos en este eje y va a ser justo
aquí y ahora darte cuenta de lo
siguiente como tenemos simetría con este
eje de simetría entonces también tenemos
este otro punto y ya se ve claramente
que así tiene que ser mi parábola ya la
podemos graficar perfecto ya aquí tengo
mi parábola y bueno en un principio en
este vídeo yo te mencionaba de que había
una fórmula para encontrar de una manera
mucho más sencilla el valor de x del
vértice de nuestra parábola
es que alguna vez vimos que el valor de
x del vértice de una palabra lo podemos
sacar como b entre 2 am y pues sería muy
bueno comprobar que en efecto llegamos
al mismo resultado
si el vértice está en el valor de x
cuando x vale menos de entre 2 am pues
entonces lo único que hay que hacer es
sustituir los valores del ibex entonces
que nos quedaría si aplicamos a esta
misma palabra pues que iba a ser igual a
menos b pero en esta ocasión b vale 8
entre dos veces a entre dos por el valor
de a que en este caso es menos 22 x
menos 2 y bueno esto cuando es
equivalente menos 8 entre menos 4 y
menos entre menos me da más porque entre
2 me da todos y entonces ya acabamos y
está perfecto porque es justo el mismo
valor que encontramos al resolver este
ejercicio de una manera mucho más
intuitiva el vértice están en el 216